I'd like to begin today by updating you
on our efforts to recover the debris
of several objects
that the United States Air Force shot down
over the last few days,
as well as that of the spy
balloon belonging to the People's
Republic of China.
And I'd like to put into some context
for you
how we have worked and are still working
to better understand the issue of high
altitude, low speed craft.
And let me start with the Chinese program.
When President Biden came into office,
he directed the U.S.
intelligence community
to do a broad assessment
of Chinese intelligence capabilities
and assure and to ensure
that we were working to detect
and to protect against them
I think for reasons
that you will all understand,
we cannot publicly go into many details
about how we discover and counteract
foreign intelligence collection.
Efforts, because much of what we have done
and are doing is, of course, sensitive.
But we were able to determine that
China has a high altitude balloon program
for intelligence collection that's
connected to the People's Liberation Army.
It was operating
during the previous administration,
but they did not detected we detected it.
We tracked it.
And we have been carefully studying it
to learn as much as we can.
We know that these PRC surveillance
balloons have crossed over
dozens of countries on multiple continents
around the world,
including some of our closest
allies and partners.
We assessed that at this time.
These balloons have provided limited
additive capabilities to the PRC's.
Other intelligence
platforms used over the United States.
But in the future, if the PRC continues
to advance this technology,
it certainly could become more valuable
to them.
The president also instructed
the intelligence community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon
of unidentified aerial objects.
Indeed, President Biden conducted
the first ever daily intelligence briefing
session devoted to this phenomenon
back in June of 2021.
He was briefed that this is not
just an issue for the United States
but one for the rest of the world.
And as I said, our friends and our
partners are dealing with this as well.
We worked
on a bipartisan basis
to stand up in office at the Pentagon
to study this in partnership
with the intelligence community,
academic institutions
and the private sector.
These unidentified aerial phenomena
have been reported for many years
without explanation
or deep examination by the government.
President Biden has changed all that.
We are finally trying to understand them
better
now in light of the Chinese
balloon program
and this recent incursion
into our airspace.
The United States and Canada
through North End have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspace, including
enhancing our radar capabilities, which,
as the commander of NORTHCOM and Noora
General Van Herc said just last night, may
at least partially explain the increase
in the objects that have been detected.
Slow moving objects at high altitude
with a small radar
cross-section
are difficult to detect on radar.
Even objects
the size of the Chinese spy balloon
which had a payload
the size of roughly three school busses,
were not picked up by previous
administrations or other countries.
We also know
that a range of entities
including countries,
companies, research and academic
organizations operate objects
at these altitudes for purposes
that are not nefarious at all,
including scientific research that said,
because we have not yet
been able to definitively assess
what these most recent objects are,
we acted out of an abundance of caution
to protect the security, our security,
our interest and flight safety
in Saturday's case.
We acted in consultation
with the Canadian government.
The president speaking personally
with Prime Minister Trudeau.
The spy balloon was, of course, different
because we knew precisely where that was.
As we have said,
we do not assess that
these most recent objects
posed any direct threat
to people on the ground,
and we are laser focused
on confirming their nature and purpose,
including through intensive efforts
to collect debris in the remote locations
where they have fallen.
In each instance,
we have followed the same basic course.
We assessed whether they posed any kinetic
threat to people on the ground.
They did not.
We assessed whether they were sending
any communications signals.
We detected none. We looked to see
whether they were maneuvering
or had any propulsion capabilities.
We saw no signs of that.
And we made sure to determine
whether or not they were manned.
They were not.
We did, however, assess
that their altitudes
were considerably lower
than the Chinese high altitude balloon
and did pose a threat
to civilian commercial air traffic.
And while we have no specific reason
to suspect that they were
conducting surveillance of any kind,
we couldn't rule that out.
That is why the president,
at the recommendation
of the secretary of defense,
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and the North NORTHCOM, nor any commander
gave the order to shoot them down.
These missions
were completed successfully and safely.
Efforts are actively underway right now
at all.
Sites to find
what is left of those objects
so that we can better understand
and communicate with the American people
what they are.
I think it's important
to remind the objects in Alaska
and Canada are in pretty remote terrain,
ice and wilderness.
All of that making it difficult
to find them in winter weather.
The object over Lake Huron now lies
in what is probably very deep water.
So outside of recovery operations,
what are we doing?
Well, first, we are continuing to monitor.
There are no active tracks today.
But the professionals at North
will continue to do their important work.
Secondly,
we are consulting with allies and partners
on the challenge
of identified aerial phenomenon
and how we can all work together
to deal with that challenge.
The president
has directed the secretary of state,
secretary of defense,
and the director of National Intelligence
to engage
with their relevant counterparts,
to share information and to try to gain
their perspectives as well.
Again, this is an issue that affects
everybody around the world.
Third, we will continue to brief members
of Congress and relevant
state leadership on what we are doing
and what we learn.
President has made this
a very top priority
We have over the course
of just the last few days and certainly
over the course of last week,
reached out to inform and brief members
of Congress and relevant state governors
of the operations that we were conducting
and the recovery operations
that are underway.
We've also kept Congress briefed generally
on this issue of Chinese surveillance
balloons, including classified briefings
last August.
And last week, administration officials
provided classified briefings
for all senators and all members of
the House of Representatives on the PRC.
Surveillance balloon.
We fully expect and anticipate and support
the ability to continue these
briefings in the days ahead.
And fourth,
the president,
through his national security adviser,
has today directed an interagency team
to study the broader policy implications
for detection, analysis and disposition
of unidentified aerial objects
that pose either safety or security risks.
Every element of the government
will redouble their efforts
to understand and mitigate these events.
And I'm happy to take some questions
John,
if the objects don't pose
a military threat
and they don't pose a threat
to the ground, why shoot them down?
Particularly because the military has
is routinely monitoring radar,
you know, radar blips.
I kind of cover that
in the opening statement.
Two real reasons here First,
there was a very real potential risk
to civilian air traffic.
The one shut down on Saturday.
I'm sorry, yesterday was about 20,000 feet
and the two shut down Friday and Saturday.
We're at about 40,000 feet.
And as you know, transcontinental air
traffic is roughly around 30,000 feet.
It depends, of course, on weather.
And so because we assessed
that they weren't manned and weren't
being controlled and therefore left
to atmospheric conditions
the real risk to safety of flight
was, was a problem.
The second purpose and I talked about this
earlier too was even though
we had no indications
that any of these three
objects were surveilling,
we couldn't rule that out.
And so there, you know, you want to err
on the side of safety here in terms of
protecting our national security interests
and the fact that these objects
could have and and likely did
at some point in their path,
transit over you know, potential military
sites of ours or sensitive sites.
So, again, out of an abundance of caution,
for those two reasons, the president,
with the recommendation of his military
leaders, directed them
to be taken down
because it's so unprecedented.
Should the public be hearing
from the president directly on this?
We have been
I think, as transparent as we can be.
I won't speak for the president's personal
speaking schedule, but,
I mean, he has been deeply engaged in
every one of these decisions.
He's been kept informed,
including as of this morning, on
what's going on with recovery efforts
And and he's very much
staying on top of the issue
and and directing his team
to make sure we are properly consulting
and briefing not just members of Congress,
but state leaders as well.
And, of course,
you know, we're also doing what we can
in the public sphere in the early weeks
Sure.
Excuse me.
Thank you, John.
What is the president's
standard going to be going forward about
when he orders
an unidentified object shot down?
It comes down to
one simple formulation, and that's
if at the recommendation
of his military leaders,
he believes that the safety
and security of the United States
the safety and security,
the American people,
his prime responsibility warrant,
that kind of a decision.
So it's possible
we could see these shutdowns
on a regular basis
like we saw over the weekend.
I don't think it's useful for me
to get ahead of where we are right now.
The president will always side
on preserving and protecting the safety
and security of the American people.
You've said we're not flying
any surveillance balloons over China.
Are we flying
any other kind of surveillance aircraft
routinely over here now
flying surveillance balloons over China?
I'm not aware of any other aircraft
that were flying over
into India, Chinese airspace.
And then finally, can you tell us
anything more about this octagonal object?
How big was it?
We're still trying to assess
what that was.
I'm not going to get into a description.
I've seen the press reports about
what would it look like.
I think we all need to be humble
here in terms of what our ability
is to positively identify stuff
from fighter aircraft that are going
several hundred miles an hour past
essentially in terms of relative motion,
a stationary object
that was not very big.
So we don't know what this exactly looked
like.
And again, we're still not sure exactly
what the purpose of it was
or who owned it.
But we we hope to be able to find out more
once we can recover the debris
from that one
and from the other two as well.
Just a few minutes ago, Prime
Minister Trudeau said
that there is some sort of pattern
to the objects over the last few days.
Is that something you could elaborate on?
What sort of pattern the White House see?
I'm not familiar
with the prime minister's comments,
so I don't know if I
if I should take a swing at that.
I would just tell you
that Going back to what I said before,
these objects were not being maneuvered.
They did not appear
to have any self propulsion.
So the likely hypothesis is
that they were being moved
by the prevailing winds.
And maybe perhaps that's what
the prime minister's talking about.
I don't want to speak for him.
But certainly as the prevailing winds,
particularly at that altitude,
go west to east or across the North
American airspace, I mean,
there was a general common movement
in that regard.
And you spoke at the top
kind of reassessing radar given
what happened with
with the initial balloon.
Can you give us a sense? Can we expect?
Should we assume
that this is the regular number
of these objects
over the United States,
that they've always been there
and they just
haven't been looked at the same way
or is there any reason to expect
that this is this is more than usual
that better flying?
So two thoughts here. I mean, I think
I think we can all
get our heads around the fact that that
there are sometimes
things floating at high altitudes
for various purposes.
As I said, scientific research, weather,
weather, balloons, all manner of
of of innocuous craft
can can be aloft at high altitudes.
I don't think that that's necessarily
unusual here.
It's difficult for for me to say exactly
what you can expect going forward.
One of the reasons that we think
we're seeing more
is because we're looking for more.
As you heard, the general van mentioned
last night, they have, um,
they have modified the filters
in the gains, as we call it,
of the, of the radar capabilities
to look more discreetly
at high altitude, small radar
cross-section and low speed objects
And so if you do that and anybody
that's operated radar will know
you can set you can set the parameters.
And if you set the parameters
in such a way that to look for a certain
something, it's more likely that
you're going to find a certain something.
Okay.
Given all you've discussed
are the actions the administration taking
and what people have learned Chinese
by balloon this year in previous years,
these unidentified objects that we shoot
down, they might have a question
when it comes to these higher altitude
as are America's border security.
The president takes, as I said earlier,
he takes our national security
extremely seriously.
He has no higher responsibility
than the safety
and security of the American people.
And I don't think you need
to look any further, quite frankly,
than the decisions he's made in
just the last week to ten days
to evidence
that feels like he's plugging holes.
Like these are vulnerabilities
that we are discovering in real time.
You're making an assumption there
that I don't know
that the analysis will actually bear out
very much.
The president gave the order to shoot
down the orbit of a Lake Huron yesterday.
Where was he?
What kind of information did he have
when he gave that order?
What was briefed to him
and how did he get a speedy outcome?
He was here in the White House.
He was kept constantly informed by by
his national security team
and certainly by the military.
He made that decision.
I don't couldn't give you the exact time
on the clock, but it was,
I believe, mid to late morning.
And and then it was executed
in the in the afternoon.
The weather continuously in place
in case there was a reaction
from a foreign government
in reaction to the shooting that took down
one of the one yesterday.
The one yesterday. Well, it was shot over.
I mean, it was shot over Lake
Huron and landed in what we believe to be
the Canadian side of the lake.
So we were obviously in constant
communication and consultation
with our Canadian counterparts.
And they are rightly because
of where we think it splashed down.
I mean, they're sort of in concert
with the U.S.
Coast Guard,
but they are also involved in
in trying to locate the debris right now.
But there was good communication
with our Canadian allies.
I, as a foreign government,
taking a special interest in that object
from yesterday,
not reacting in an unusual way. No.
Being in the
of two questions.
One, you mentioned early on that
this the China
balloon might have been giving limited
additive capabilities.
I assume you
meaning onto their satellites were built.
Can you specify what I mean,
what exactly it's getting
from a balloon that they're not getting
from orbiting satellites?
That goes obviously with the caveat
that we haven't fully recovered
everything that we have recovered
some things from the bottom of the
of the Atlantic
and we're analyzing that.
But with that caveat,
we don't know exactly
what this balloon
was surveilling
or what its capabilities were.
So just in general and that is important
caveat that I'd like you to remember
when you are at a lower
altitude than space,
you could perhaps get a better fidelity
of of of imagery, for instance,
of things on the ground
when you are not moving
at the speed of a satellite and therefore,
you know, only getting seconds over a seat
when you can maneuver
left, right,
Slow down, speed up like this thing could.
Then you can loiter.
If you can loiter,
you can soak in a little bit more.
You can spend more time
over a sensitive side
of some of the satellites
or in geostationary orbit.
I mean, they're just sitting there
gathering signals intelligence right on.
What is the benefit?
I mean, is it just to see what kind of
fidelity we're going to learn more?
I'd rather not go into any more detail
than that right now.
We're going to learn more.
And frankly, I think that's a terrific
question you should be asking Beijing.
And the last one of the you said that
the before of the other object shot
that we're not able to transmit
or we're not transmitting signals
that they did not have any propulsion
that the China balloon.
Did that have any was it
emitting signals back?
I'm not going to go into more detail
about the the capabilities of that.
We are going to be studying it
and analyzing it.
There is no question in our mind that
that system was designed to surveil that.
That was an intelligence asset.
I'll leave it there.
There
isn't continuing outreach
from anywhere in the administration
to the kinds of companies
that produce weather
balloons or other
craft that would fit these descriptions
that might be from the commercial
or corporate world to say,
is this yours or any kind of outreach?
Or have you been hearing from
anyone who might say,
we have ours there in this area?
Is any of that going on now?
I don't know of any conversations right
now, Kelly, but one of the reasons
why the president directed Mr.
Sullivan to put together
an interagency effort is to take a long
look at that
and try to learn a little bit better about
who is up at that altitude doing what
for completely legitimate purposes.
I think we
we all recognize we need to probably have
a better side picture on that.
And that's why the president wants
this interagency effort to take a look.
And what kind of intelligence might be
happening in terms of the diplomacy
that's going on or whatever?
If these are state owned
objects, I'm not sure I understand
what you mean.
Is there is there a network
of conversations that might be happening
where someone might be able to say,
based on this act,
the octagonal description, that, hey,
that sounds like the so-and-so?
I mean, is there some conversations
that are happening that might be able
to give us some descriptions?
I mean, the short
answer to your question is yes.
And I talked about that
in my opening statement.
The president also directed
Secretary Blinken, Secretary
Austin Director Haines,
to have these kinds of conversations
with our allies and partners
around the world to share with them
what we're learning, but also to see get
get their perspectives.
We are quick to say it's ours,
but it was for commercial purposes.
Yeah.
Again, we're going to have those kinds
of conversations with our other
allies and partners to see
what kind of experiences they have had
with what we can learn from from them,
what perhaps they can learn from us.
And are we still with object or
can we call them balloon's still object?
And just to follow up on Kelly
and I won't mess that up today
on the corporate angle.
Is there any expectation
that this is going to affect the executive
order on surveilling the U.S.
companies and what they're doing in China?
I mean, they're I know of no change there.
Exactly. Okay.
And then is there any just
you said a moment ago that there's
no knowledge of a U.S.
balloon or other craft over
Chinese territory,
just being cognizant of the fact
that China has a different definition
of what
their territory is than the United States?
Is there any U.S.
surveillance aircraft over Taiwan,
right over the South China Sea
that that would would fit into that?
There is no U.S.
surveillance
aircraft over Chinese in Chinese airspace.
Even Chinese claimed airspace,
you know, U.S.
surveillance aircraft in Chinese airspace.
And then just finally,
is there any new formal approach
that's being developed
as far as how you're going to deal
with these things on a systematic basis
going forward?
Is there?
Well, again, again, that's what that's
exactly what the the president wants Mr.
Sullivan to run is a process,
an interagency process to help
us, as I said in my opening statement,
getting around the policy
implications here
and whether and whether
or not there needs to be any
policy changes going forward.
It's a picture no precedent for U.S.
players taking down objects over U.S.
territory, as far as I'm aware of.
My question is, you talked about the tweak
in the radar systems.
Yes, there have been a tweak.
The threshold for
the Pentagon
that was presented to the president,
president signing off on military action
related to anything over our airspace.
I'm not sure I'm following which
in the wake of the Chinese spy plane.
Yeah, the radars were tweaked,
which is why you think
we're seeing some of these things. Right.
Has the decision about or has thresholds
for the use of fighters to take down
objects also between has it been lowered?
Has it been changed? We've never seen this
before all of a sudden.
No, actually, I'm sorry.
I didn't understand it at first.
No, I mean and you heard General Van
talk about this last night,
and he's using established protocols
to engage
the craft and in the air
aircraft in the air
that can be legitimately brought down.
And as he said last night,
the best way to do that,
certainly in a timely and efficient,
effective way, was through fighter
aircraft and through the Sidewinder
air to air missiles.
And they looked at
and he talked about this,
they looked at other options to try
to bring them down to include gunfire.
But that would have presented a greater
risk to the pilots themselves.
So this was the safest,
most effective way to do that.
Now, where we go from here,
I think we just don't know right now
in terms of whether there needs to be
a threshold changes as you put out.
I think it's important
to just take a step back here.
And what the president did
was all these actions
with the safety and security
of American people foremost in his mind.
And there were
there were very good reasons to do it.
The military then,
once given an order, determined
how they're going to execute that order
and General Ban
Hurt decided that the best way to do
this was with Sidewinder missiles
and fighter aircraft.
Sure. Before.
This isn't reactive to the Chinese fighter
alone in the sense of
there was political pressure.
And so we are going to act quickly
to take down any objects
over our airspace
because of the pressure that came from
this was this was
these were decisions based
purely and simply
on what was in the best interests
of the American people in general.